toujours pas de nouvelles de notre
confrère et de notre ami philippe de
dieuleveult ainsi que de ses six
compagnons d'aventuré situation qui
inquiète ce qui l'avait accompagné dans
la première partie de son périple parmi
lesquels gérard d'aboville l'homme qui
traversa l'atlantique à la rame
d'aboville et deux autres explorateurs
sont partis pour le zaïre afin de
rechercher eux aussi cette expédition
perdu mais je voudrais maintenant que
vous écoutiez ce document exclusif dans
lequel philippe de dieuleveult parle de
son aventure c'était au moment de
s'embarquer sur la langue anika roland
sicard
voici les deux équipages de l'expédition
philippe de dieuleveult une expédition à
travers l'afrique équatoriale caméra en
main l'afrique mais je ne connaissais
pas du tout la région des grands lacs et
j'ai joué avec venir burundi c'était
pour moi une rave
j'y suis je suis sur le lac tanganyika
je suis heureux et je vais partir donc
avec toute l'équipe et en plus avec mes
amis parce que j'ai contacté gérard
d'aboville qui a tout de suite dit ok
j'ai contacté françois laurens ou le
médecin qui a dit ok et mark durno qui
va s'occuper de la radio et nous allons
donc tenter de sortir un document de 52
minutes mais les conditions de tournage
mais difficile vous en doutez avec
l'humidité et avec 20 lolo sur laquelle
nous nous serons tout le temps qu'est ce
que je vais faire découvrir ses parts
contre notre vraie aventure laventure
que nous allons vivre la réaction des
gens qui vont être sur les bateaux est
confronté au problème donc de santé de
manger de dormir ça ne va pas être drôle
tous les jours on sait mais on est là
aussi pour pour se tester
personnellement pour savoir comment on
est capable de réagir et je vais peut
être essayer d'intéresser un peu plus
justement aux réactions humaines c'est
ce qui m'intéresse dans ce film le
matériel a été spécialement conçu pour
l'opération une première franchir les
rapides du fleuve zaïre sur deux radeaux
pneumatiques nous avons opté pour une
un pneumatique gonflables ont réparti en
cinq compartiments d'autre part ces deux
les deux flotteurs sont unis par
un cadre métallique en inox qui permet
une certaine élasticité entre flotteurs
ce bateau est propulsé
par des moteurs hors bord en partant
partie calme et à l'aide d'aviron
en partie mouvementée c'est à dire en
rapide en ce qui concerne les les
particularités on peut s'arrêter sur les
panneaux solaires les panneaux solaires
sont destinés à alimenter les deux
radios que nous trouvons sur chaque
bateau ce sont des radios qui sont
insubmersibles
elle permet de communiquer entre les
bateaux sur une pente sur une portée de
50 à 70 kilomètres en zone dégagée
à partir de ces radios nous pouvons
capter des émissions émises de france
mais ne pouvons pas émettre pour émettre
nous avons un autre système de radio que
nous mettons en place exclusivement la
nuit avec une antenne qui sera tendue
d'un d'un arbre à l'autre à travers le
fleuve
le départ a été donnée début juillet du
lac tanganyika à l'embouchure du zaïre
2700 km mais la course des deux radeaux
s'est arrêté dans les rapides d'inga